She knew, for example, in Venezuela, in the USA, in the Humboldt, Greenland, Mount Hum, and New Caledonia.
Yeah, he was more than an explorer.
He was an ecologist, someone who observes and tries to understand the harmony and the forces of nature.
A humanist as well.
He would defend human rights at all times.
Mind if I continue?
So much the Humboldt story.
Where do I begin?
I'll start at the beginning.
This is Paris in the year 1798.
Monsieur, I wasn't paying attention.
Entirely my fault, monsieur.
I was thinking.
Permit me to introduce myself.
Alexander von Humboldt from Berlin.
Et mes bons plans, La Rochelle.
How do you do?
You are a botanist.
A doctor.
But plants interest me.
And you appear to be an astronomer.
Well, not exactly.
I'm interested in a great deal.
In all of nature.
I think we might work together.
It would be useful to compare notes.
Maybe we could go together on an expedition.
Why not?
It's true.
The world's full of so much to discover.
Plants.
Yes, the very laws of nature.
Human beings.
Ah, His Majesty Carlos IV, King of Spain, Baron Alexander von Humboldt of Berlin, scholar and philosopher, and Monsieur Aimé Bonpland, French botanist.
Gentlemen, you wish to explore our colonies out in America. Well, why is that?
For pure science, Your Majesty. In these regions, our plants and animals never cataloged. Whole peoples are known.
Only a Frenchman, Monsieur de la Condamine, published a book about the area.
These days, expeditions are costly, and we're not rich.
But sire, the Baron von Humboldt is quite prepared to finance the expedition entirely
and graciously, without charge, give everything he collects to our museums.
Oh, in that case, well, may I wish you a happy voyage.
I will instruct all my governors and prefects and captains and, well, you know,
to assist you in any way they can.
But be warned, such places are very dangerous.
Someone here in the prime of life, admire the man's teeth.
Slavery's wrong. People have a right to be free.
I know that one day South America will follow the example of North America and Europe.
There's going to be a revolution down here.
Do you really think so?
The Spanish are in power here and they won't give it out.
You are right, senores.
One day we will get our liberty.
You can't speak our language?
Yes, senor.
Also many Indian dialects.
I know the area very well and I'm an expert at paddling canoes.
Are you interested in working for us, joining our expedition?
Yes, I am.
Where are you headed?
To the south.
Up the Orinoco, all the way to the Amazon.
Wait, come over here, to where we can talk.
First, we have to cross the plains on horseback.
Then, we must find a dugout canoe to buy.
What is your name?
My name is Carlos.
If you want, we can leave to Morisana.
Careful, it could be poisonous.
It's a milk treat, delicious, not poison.
I wouldn't drink that.
If the Indians always drink it, why can't I?
Careful of him, senor. It is quite dangerous. It will shoot lightning bolts so big they will kill a horse, senor.
No more Carlos. Kill a horse?
Si, senor. I saw one do it.
Then I'll have to examine it. This animal is unique.
Now, wait a minute. I have an idea.
Hola, amigo. Paella bonia buscada, ma horse.
Huh?
This is really extraordinary. An electric shock.
Look there. That horse is practically dead.
You see, this organ builds up an electrical charge.
It's a powerful weapon for this strange creature.
Bells there are noon. Must have one.
Mucho dinero para todos.
This river is the Apurri. It will lead to the Orinoco. It will take a few days.
These trees are gigantic. It's hard to believe.
The Orinoco, you see it? There!
Welcome, welcome!
Hello, I'm Brother Zeer. You're looking for a canal linking the Orinoco to the Rio Negro, which will bring you to the Amazon.
Condamine in his early exploration said that there was a canal.
Brother Alonso went up the Orinoco.
Mm-hmm.
He assures me there can be no such canal.
Well, that we shall see.
In any case, you won't go far in that nutshell there.
You will need a much larger boat, a sturdier one, and porters.
And if you like, I will be glad to accompany you on your journey.
But now you must come to the monastery and take your refreshment.
To with the Indians, there are some fish hooks, some leaves of tobacco,
two small cakes of alcohol, and two more.
No, no, no, no.
Oh, my, oh, my rapid.
An animal.
Sure be better that way.
No!
The boat is just a few feet away.
It's much simpler than I get.
Piranha fish, eat up all.
You lucky this time.
Quite a specimen.
Almost ten feet long, that one.
Casquiare Canal.
The one that Condamine wrote about.
Oh.
The boat, it's turning into Noah's Ark.
This far.
The Indians gave us this as gifts from tame toucans.
Mmm.
Pardon.
Those toucans are becoming good parishioners, Padre.
Haha.
I will headache.
My head is bursting.
Malaria.
All those mosquitoes, they carry the disease.
We'll return to Angostura. You'll be alright.
Quickly, prepare the quinine.
Drink this.
This is quinine, just what you need. Drink it up.
How's Bonplan?
He's no better, alas.
Senor, your friend, and Bonplan, you mean.
Si, senor. He does not move anymore.
Oh, I'll go. Bonplan.
Reaction in the pupil, his heart is beating, he's alive!
More quinine!
There. A good sign.
Better now. We thought we were going to lose you.
I feel better, Padre, only I would like...
Yes, some more quidines.
Oh, not exactly.
Home, if it's possible.
Carlos?
You called me, senor?
Would you please shave me?
I'm here to pray, but I'm also looking for someone.
Someone?
The young lady has returned to her village upriver.
Oh, I'm much obliged, Padre.
Senor, she is upriver at her home.
I know, but I love her.
It's impossible to go on living without her.
Senor!
It's incredible, it's totally unknown.
A mushroom big as that.
It's incredible!
A macrolepidopterus, another species, totally unknown. It's fantastic. That is a Denrobatus, but with many stripes, completely new.
Well, Carlos, do you think he'll ever come back?
Well, it's sure, senor. He will return with his arms full of new discoveries.
Xander, look at this butterfly and how about this frog? They're remarkable.
Good for you, my friend. You are finding everything that you're looking for.
Go in peace, my children. You both deserve some good rest.
More than 2,000 kilometers in this strange land.
But now, much less strange.
Yes, and having the company of alligators and of boar constrictors, vampire bats, is hardly ever boring here.
Delivery of 60 slaves, everyone in excellent health.
Trouble is tenable, died on the way forward.
You should be ashamed. They have the right to be free.
Every human being is free.
What? Who does he...
Yes, who does he think he is?
We just couldn't live here without slaves.
Everybody knows that blacks aren't human.
I agree. Slavery is something we must never allow.
It must be stopped, of course.
Can we do? After all, we're just two.
I don't know. We'll leave this country. Go someplace else to Bogota.
There we can explore the Andes.
Andes, the Andes, the Andes.
The world's longest mountain chain.
7,000 kilometers long, the peaks are more than 6,000 meters up.
Snow that never melts, volcanoes always erupting.
So, leaving from Quito, the ancient Inca capital, 2,500 meters above sea level,
our friend set off to explore the Andes Mountains.
And there'll never have a man or any living thing.
They feed on dead carcasses.
They're scavengers.
Oh, yuck.
Oh, I mustn't think bad of them.
They keep everything clean.
Look, Borazzo.
Goes up 6,000 meters, a mountain no one's been able to climb.
No wonder.
Much too high to climb.
We will start our ascent tomorrow.
Hey, who's we?
Go no further.
But without you, we can't go up.
This mountain's sacred.
Indians cannot go up.
We stay here.
The way up?
Then let's go up.
Close and feed.
We will keep going.
Oxygen.
It's the low air pressure, the lack of oxygen.
We're very high.
It causes the bleeding and it's serious. We'll go down.
Yes, but we're nearly there. Let's go on.
We could wait and see when we get accustomed to the height.
Oh, sit up.
Ah, too bad we're waiting a few hundred meters of the summit.
Nobody has ever climbed higher.
The record.
But now we have to go down.
It was right here the Inca Emperor at Hualpa
told the conquistador Pizarro he'd fill up
a whole room would go this high as he could reach for his freedom.
An attack if you release him.
What else?
Last, here we are. The Pacific Ocean.
Strange. So few trees about.
In fact, very little vegetation. I wonder why.
It's cold. I mean cold.
Shove off. Let's go.
See, the water is cold.
That's why this particular region has little rainfall and is as out as a desert.
Yes, but what explains it?
It's because the cold water cools down the air just above it.
Cold air holds less moisture.
But when it reaches the land, it warms up and absorbs moisture.
There is high humidity and this turns into heavy fog.
So it rains.
But not before passing over the mountains.
The human air rises over the mountains, the Andes going to the east.
On the other side is where it reigns.
Washington, the brand new capital of the United States, which has just won its independence.
All rise for Thomas Jefferson, President of the United States of America.
Baron von Humboldt, it is a pleasure to welcome you.
I've heard much about your explorations and your good work.
And of yours too, Monsieur Bonpland.
Mr. President, the countries of South America are about to be free and democratic, just as your country.
But a problem still has to be resolved, sir.
And what is this problem?
An enormous problem, Mr. President.
Slavery.
You cannot maintain your democracy when you put human beings in slavery because they have black skin.
The people of Berlin are rising up against injustice, shooting in the streets.
That's right, Karl.
There are still some ready to die for liberty.
I want to see this.
At the age of 90, Humboldt completed the last volume of his great work, Cosmos.
He tried to explain that all the forces and physical parts of the world come together to form a unity.
What causes winds and currents is just a part of the whole.
Humanist, liberal, founder of ethnology and anthropology, the study of human society,
humble tide, having completed a body of work that was gigantic.